the Joe Rogan experience um it's like
the knees right to me my knees are kind
of trash but when I workout and stretch
and warm them up they're not it's not
bad and I've talked to doctor and doctor
like yet eventually we're gonna do a
knee replacement but you don't need it
you know arthritis just you know you
don't have to do a knee replacement yeah
tensor stem cells which is something I
may do my mom did it I know I've heard
you talk about it and yeah that might be
the way as a matter of fact I have a
friend and she's like in her she's
around 80 and she said yeah that's what
they did for her knee they did stem so
my mom had her knees replaced before she
passed away and she said yeah that's one
of the things you inherited from us bad
knees it's like in the fans like thank
you but but she also made me funny so I
couldn't really be mad at her she did
great so I was like I'll take the funny
and the bad knees the bad knees are
workable yeah I'm telling you CBD first
of all is gonna help that because it
reduces the all the symptoms of
arthritis like Dave Foley
his hands were [ __ ] up he had like
some severe arthritis in his hands CBD
completely cured it he cleans straight
in his hands out his hands were always
at like a slight Bend now now he's got a
full range of motion in his hands he's
blown away by it yeah my knee problem is
impact you know just Paul or basketball
basketball yeah so even the meniscus and
all that's right trashed so even now
like I I can do most like I can't jump
you know I can run I can do so I did
this CrossFit I tried CrossFit and my
knees fall up and I went to my doctor
anything cross what the hell is wrong
you jumping up on boxes my my my
doctor's diagnosis for 90% of my
problems you're old don't do that you
can you can fix a lot of those problems
with stem cells a lot of those problems
yeah it regenerates tissue reduces
inflammation it does a lot of amazing
stuff now and and I haven't researched
this at all I mean you know I've heard
stuff up my stem cell knowledge is about
equal to my climate change
mine is not lightly better right so I've
actually had a bunch done on me well
this is what I wanted to ask you about
so I know when you talked about it early
on you went overseas right you laughs
that was my question because I've heard
people talking about going to Panama
Panama Asia
but dr. Reardon who's the guy who
treated Mel Gibson and Mel Gibson's dad
he actually treated my mom my mom was in
risk of a knee replacement you know
she's in pretty you know pretty bad pain
and the doctors like you got to get an e
replace and I'm like okay maybe you have
to get a knee replacement but before you
do that let's send you to Panama and
they'll they'll do this full three-day
stem-cell procedure they use IV stem
cells they they they blast the area over
three different days they hit it with
stem cells mm-hmm and you know my mom is
73 so it was a while before it worked
she you know for the first four months
she was a little discouraged she like I
don't feel anything different you know I
don't know if this is working and then
somewhere around five six months she
started feeling a lack of pain and the
pain just start stop gonna just stop
being like a part of her daily life
right and now she could walk and it's
not bothering her she was I'm walking
with no pain I can walk up hills with no
pain and she goes I want to do it again
so I was like [ __ ] it let's send you
down again see she's she's headed down
again to get more of it but you did it
here yeah I did it here well I think no
is there a difference yes they can they
can go ham in Panama they go ham they
just bring a [ __ ] bucket of stumps
there's they don't have the same
regulation right they do in America so
they can get away with a lot of
different stuff and dr. Reardon who is
one of the pioneers of this and he's
written multiple papers and yes you know
scientific journals all about the
benefits of stem cells and it's
particularly effective on people with
neurological conditions people with
neurodegenerative diseases like and he's
written extensively about all that stuff
but when he came on he
he blew me away and I had already had
some success with stem cells in America
where like I had a full-length rotator
cuff tear in my shoulder right and they
injected it with exosomes which is like
the most advanced form of stem so these
who it was the waste they used to think
is stem cells they felt like when you
put stem cells into an injury that the
stem cells were repro liberating this
area with new tissue but now they think
that the stem cells
I'm sure I'm butchering butchering this
if you're scientist now I think they
think the stem cells are releasing
exosomes and that the exosomes are
actually what does it so now they just
go straight to exosomes and then they
inject exosomes into these particular
areas now they have another product
called Wharton's jelly that's even more
potent that I just got shot into me
yeah my name's Hannah I get an injured
man I just [ __ ] head on down yeah
what's the purpose of having money if
I'm not [ __ ] shooting myself up but
okay you go juicy stem cells you go it
works I hope I got stem cell cash I
probably do you do it's not that yeah no
I do medium listen Amazon special no I
do listen I do all right tell people I
do or I don't make as much as they think
but I do all right you know what I mean